هذه العائلات على يمين الكاميرا التي
ستشاهدينها اشعل النيران هنا للتدفئه ولن
يغادروا هذا المكان حتى يعثروا على
ذويه الذين لا زالوا تحت الانقاض فبالتالي
البرد خارج نعم مع ساعات المساء بدا البرد
فعلا يصبح قارئ جدا ولذلك هذه العائلات
مستقره طبعا كانت قبل قليل سيده
منهاره جدا وتبكي وتصرخ بان لديها اثنين
من اسرتها تحت انقاذ وانها تشتكي من قله
وجود كوادر لانقاذ والاليات الثقيله للعمل
ولكن بالفعل الجهود جباره التي تبذل يعني
هنالك من يلوم رجال الانقاذ لانه صاحب
حاجه لانه يريد لاسرائيل لمن لمن يخصه من
تحت الانقاض ان يظهر ويعود الى الحياه ان
كان على قيد الحياه او حتى يعرف مصيره
ولكن في المقابل هذا في الواقع يعني فيه
شيء من التجني لان الجنود كبيره جدا جدا
جدا
ومقارنه وقياسا بالعدد الكبير للمباني
المدمره
هنا فيها